[Music]
ellen's with us in chicago hi ellen how
are you
doing good how are you dave
better than i deserve merry christmas
merry christmas
i am having a problem
uh 2021 nora 2020 has been very kind to
me
even though we are
just on the edge i hate to say the edge
because it's going to be probably in
another year
um of paying off debt
uh my aunt passed away last month and
she left
me as the beneficiary of one of her
insurance policies
and
when the dust settles i should say once
we get all the paperwork straightened
out and i
get everything it looks like i've got
three thousand dollars coming in
and
the temptation
what i know what i should do everything
should go on our debt that's left
you know it's not to pay off the debt by
far but it means
it's another three thousand dollars that
we are getting ahead
uh the problem is
there's all these things in my mind
going we know there's this
shiny thing and
i know i have mental issues i know i
have
problems with impulse
this is an ongoing thing i'm
got medical treatment i've medicine i've
got um well i've got that antidepressant
i should say i'm seeing a counselor
weekly on this
um
because
yes i'm married
it sounds like can i can i say something
that's going to be hard to hear
yes john sounds like you're planning for
failure and i want you to plan for
success
and it's easy to plan for failure when
you feel like you have failed yourself
over and over and over again you feel
like that
yeah i can feel this i can hear the
shame through the phone i want you to
let that go and set that down it's
nonsense
you're here and the beautiful thing
about being right here is
you can own what happened in the past
and now you can say
starting today
and if you plan for success
you're going to stumble along the way
because you're practicing a new way of
living you're practicing a new way of
thinking you're practicing a new way of
being in a relationship with yourself
and other people but you're practicing
it
and just like lebron james will take a
thousand shots today at practice and
he'll miss a chunk of them just so he
can hit more shots in the game i want
you to practice it i want you to start
by saying i'm gonna put this three
thousand bucks i'm gonna honor my aunt
because i'm the kind of woman who honors
her family members and their stewardship
of their money
i'm gonna put on debt it's the right
place for it to go and then you may have
to set up a roadblock or two you may
have to make sure it deposits into an
account that you don't have access to or
give up your atm card for a season uh
your debit card for a season whatever
that looks like but set up a roadblock
or two for yourself
yeah a good way to do that is get people
you love in your life and say to your
husband um
i i want you to hold my hand so that i
make it so that i write the check and it
goes to debt
and i want you to walk with me and help
me do this and he can't
he can't say oh no honey it's yours you
do whatever no i need your help i need
you to walk with me and give me the
strength to do the smart thing
yeah yeah exactly
i i think you can do it ellen
we've paid off a hundred thousand
dollars so far over a hundred thousand
dollars so far i take back what i just
said i know you can do it
i know you can
yeah you know what else you know what
else indicates that you can
that you called here you're called here
yeah
i mean somebody who couldn't wouldn't
have called here
but you called here you just wanted us
to remind you that you can do it that's
our job we remind people stuff they
already know that's right ellen i want
you this weekend i want you to get an
hour by yourself for two hours and i
want you to write your anna letter
tell her much you love her and what
you're grateful for
and how much you're gonna miss her
and tell her what you're gonna do with
that money that money's gonna go to
continuing to pay off your debt so that
you and your husband can be free